[Music]
with the clock ticking down to the world
cup fifa has begun looking for what it
calls the heart of the tournament the
volunteers to help put on a successful
event
football's governing body president
janine pantino was at a glitzy event in
qatar's capital doha to encourage fans
to sign up it will of course be an
incredible journey
a journey that will give you
memories that will follow you for
your entire life
but
more important than that
you are
the first face the first smile that any
visitor to qatar will find when he comes
here as with previous world cups
volunteers will work across stadiums
training sites the airport and fan zones
they'll be there to help some of the
million expected visitors to the country
find their way so we're really looking
for volunteers who are you know who want
to help who who have that smile who have
that openness and we see every world cup
they bring really the joyful atmosphere
uh to the world cup i call it the glue
you know and the glue is important
because
they help to bring all the dynamics
together for such a massive tournament
qatar is looking for 20 000 volunteers
for this year's tournament that's more
than the 17 000 that worked in russia
four years ago and more than the 14 000
that worked in brazil in 2014.
applications are open on fifa's website
you must be at least 18 years old by
october the first and can come from
anywhere in the world but must be able
to speak english
but being a volunteer doesn't entitle
you to a ticket to any of the games and
it's worth remembering that volunteers
won't be paid and they'll have to cover
all of their transport and accommodation
costs to get to qatar
world cup organizers though are keen to
stress that it's an opportunity to be
part of history at the first world cup
in the middle east
come to qatar
and be the open arms
be the welcoming smile and the cheerful
voice of our country and the region
be the heart
be the soul be the energy that everyone
feels
during the world cup
qatar has signed up to host the biggest
show in football but it's hoping the
world will come to help
joanna gesrowska al jazeera doha